ก็สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องอัญตี
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนเย้
เจอกันอีกแล้วด้วยกันอีกแล้วตอนนี้ครับผม
ข้าขี่โมงใช่ไหมครับตอนนี้ตอนนี้เวลา
10:00 นครับ
สิบโมงครึ่งไหนครับ 10:30 นปากกาครัวตี้
ไปไหนห้าสิบ
โมง 10:30 นนโมงครึ่งนะใครครับสิบโมง
ครึ่งตอนนี้ครับเรากินเสร็จแล้วเนาะกิน
เสร็จแล้วครับพิมพ์เสร็จแล้วนะครับไปกิน
แล้วส้มตำกินส้มตำเสร็จแล้วเก่งแล้วตอน
นี้อิ่มอิ่ม
แล้ว
มะครับพูดวันกันก่อนค่ะวันเหนื่อยคะอ้าว
วันนี้วันนี้วันอะไรวันนี้วันศุกร์ค่ะ
เมื่อวันศุกร์ใช่ค่ะนี้วันศุกร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่วันศุกร์วันที่ 10 ครับวัน
นี้อ้าวันศุกร์ที่ 10 ทรายครับ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนนี้นี่เดือนนี้เดือน
ธันวาคมขั้นว่าถ้าทำธันวาคมมาใส่ครับปีคศ
ทีข้อสองพัน
21 ครับ
ของคัน 21  41 ทรายขับปีกพ.ต.เท่าไหร่คะ
ผช
2564 ครับเนอะ
514 ค้าในครับ
[เพลง]
ครับที่ออกทริปที่แล้วถามครู Arty กับครู
เอ๋พูดรถเข็นหารถเข็นขั้นต่ำแล้วสองคนคุย
กันเสร็จก็เบรคไปกินไปกินเสร็จแล้ว 5
อิ่มแล้วครู Arty ที่ประเทศไทยในซอย
ปฏิวัติซอยได้ไหมคะในซอยได้ไหมครับอ่ะใน
ซอยก็จะเป็นนี้ถนนไหมครับถนน
ถนนใหญ่และนี้น่ะถนนหลักถนนกระบี่ต่อต่อย
นี่ 2 ซอยย่อยๆครับน้ามีตอยก็มีซอยเล็กๆ
มีซอยข้างในอีกค่าอาหารๆ
ในซอย
หรือบางทีที่ถนนข้าวจะมีรถเข็นใช่ๆอ่ามี
รถเขต
คิดที่แล้ว 2 คนพูดรถเข็นส้มสีดำอ้าวแต่
ที่ซอยมีรถเข็นยางอื่นไม่ใช่ส้มตำไหมคะ
อ้ามีครับมีรถเข็น R อย่างอื่นที่ไม่ใช่
ส้มตำนะกูรถเข็นอะไรคะ 5 มีรถเข็นลูกชิ้น
ปิ้งครับฮ่าๆนี่อันนี้รถรถเข็นรูปชิ้น
ปิ้งดายครับ
ปิ้งลูกชิ้นทอดใช้กับมีทั้งแบบปิ้งแล้วก็
ทอด
งั้นอยากดูลูกชิ้นปิ้งอ๋ออ๋อนี่มีลูกชิ้น
ปิ้งเยอะเลยนี่ครับมีลูกชิ้นเยอะเลย
ว้าวอะไรบ้างคะหน้ามีลูกชิ้นอะไรบ้างใช่
ไหมครับอันใหญ่ๆได้ไหมคะใหญ่ๆเอาลูกชิ้น
ไหนก่อนครับนี่เอาใหม่เออตรงนี้ครับ
กดเอ๋รู้นะกู Arty ครับอ่าต่ำที่มือที่
อ่าทุกวันที่ชีสลุกชิ้น
[เพลง]
ตรงสีเขาขาวๆตรงนี้ใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับตรงนี้
ลูกชิ้นปลาหน้ามีลูกชิ้นปลาสีขาว
รู้จัก
5 ป่าวๆไม่เป็นไร
ถ้าเป็นมีกระดาษ
ปลา
อาจาร์ยลูกชิ้นปลา
เพลง
ว้าว
มีลูกชิ้นปลาแล้วมีลูกชิ้นอะไรอีก 5
พรุ่งนี้ตรงนี้กลัวแต่คิดว่าเป็นลูกชิ้น
กุ้งครับลูกก็ครึ่งๆ
ลูกชิ้นกุ้งหน้า
ลูกชิ้นกุ้งเยอะเลยลูกชิ้นพุ่งไม่รู้ชิ้น
กุ้ง
เหมือนค่ะดูรู้เป็นกุ้งหน้าลูกชิ้นกุ้งไง
ครับก็อ้าโอ้สีชมพูอะไรกูสีชมลูกกินอะไร
ยาวใช่ลูกชิ้นไหมคะ
ยาวเรียกเรียกไส้กรอก
ไม่ใช่ลูกชิ้นไปให้ใช่รู้หรอกไงครับเป็น
ไส้กรอก
กรอกคิดว่าจะ
หมูไหมอ่ากว่าตี้คิดว่าหมูครับไส้กรอกหมู
ในครับ 5 สีสีชมพู
สีชมพู
ก็จะเป็นไส้กรอกหมู
5 แล้วก็มีลูกชิ้นอะไรใกล้ๆไส้กรอกหมู
ใกล้ๆไส้กรอกหมูตรงนี้เป็นลูกชิ้นปลาหมึก
ครับอ่ะลูกชิ้นปลาหมื่นนะมีลูกชิ้นปลา
หมึกด้วยนะครับชิ้นปลาหมึก
ใกล้ๆไม่ๆมีไส้กรอกอีกใช้กรอกอะไรคะไป
กรอกอันนี้ไส้กรอกรมควันครับ
รมควันน่าใช้ครับเรียกว่าไส้กรอกรมควัน
ใช่ครับ
มีไส้กรอกเยอะๆนะคะนายมีไส้กรอกรมควัน
เยอะเลยนะครับอย่าเยอะแยะพรุ่งนี้ครับตรง
นี้อะไรอ่ะนี้เป็นอ่าอ่ะเป็นหมูยอยอหมูยอ
เรียกว่าหมูยอนี้นะคะเน้นหน้ากูยอสีขาว
หน้าในครับตรงนี้มีลูกชิ้นอีกครับมีลูก
ชิ้นอะไรตรงนี้เป็นลูกชิ้นเนื้อรู้สิน
เนื้อวัวลูกชิ้นเนื้อวัวคนไทยเรียกเนื้อ
คนในเรียกสั้นๆลูกชิ้นหนึ่งนะ
[เพลง]
แล้วบัวอันนี้มาหาทรายกับเดี๋ยววัวบ่อ
หมอเหมือนวัวครับมีข้าวนะโอเค
วัวเนื้อเวลา
หารูปน่าจะดีกว่านะคะ
Way ไหม
เอ๋พี่เอ๋วัว
มีปลา
ปลาฉลามอ่ะและ
วัววายุคินเนื้อวัวแต่ขับมีลูกชิ้น
หัวนี้นะครับเวลาเอาวัวมาทำกลมกลมพูดลูก
ชิ้นนะคะ
วัว
แล้วมีอะไรอ่ะไกลๆลูกชิ้นเนื้อวัวไอ้ใกล้
ลูกชิ้นเนื้อวัว
ชั้นไหนครับครูเอ๋อันนี้
คืออันนี้
ค่ะๆอันที่สองที่เพราะอันที่ 1 ก่อนก็ได้
ค่ะ
อันที่ 1 กินแล้ววัวเหมือนกันใช่ไหมอ่ะ
ใส่ครับเนื้อวัวเหมือนกันอ่ะลูกชิ้นเนื้อ
วัวและสีชมพูราคะสีชมพูอันนี้ใช่ไหมครับ
หานี่เป็นอะไรก็มีช่วยปวดที่คิดว่ากูเอก
รู้จักกูมารู้จักช่อนี้ดีมากเพจชอบ TM
นี้ใช่ครับอันนี้อะไรค่อนขอ
[เพลง]
ผมคิดว่าเป็นลูกชิมปู
เดี๋ยวว่างปู่ให้
ปู่นี่ค่ะอ๋อปู่มีเก้าตำปูใจครับเหมือนขา
ก้ามปูเป็นก้ามปู
ทำก็เป็น
ก้ามปูๆเป็นก้ามปูอ่ะตรงนี้ก็เป็นปู
เหมือนกันนี่เขากูเหมือนกันกูอัดๆครับกู
อ่ารักกูอ่าอะหน้าแล้วใกล้ๆปูอัดกลมๆอัน
นี้กลมอันนี้เป็นหมูหมูหมูสับหมูๆๆเป็น
หมูสับในครับนะคะ
หือขอ KR เลือกลูกชิ้นแล้วหาเลือกลูกชิ้น
แล้วก็จะเอาไปทำอะไรครับที่นิดเอาไปยาก
ตายเราไปที่ร้านลูกชิ้นเราเลือกเองล่ะคดี
หาให้ครับเราเลือกเองเอาอันนี้เอาอันนี้
เอาอันดิเวลาที่ไม่รู้ไม่รู้ว่าชื่อเรียก
อะไรไม่รู้เอาอันนี้อันนี้ฮิฮิอันนี้
อันนี้ทรายแตกครับถ้านักเรียนไม่รู้ชื่อ
อะไรข่าวผีฮ่าๆแต่ถ้านักเรียนเอ้ย
กุ้งมา
วัวหรือหมูนักเรียนขามได้อันนี้อะไรคะ
หาครูเอ๋ไม่กินเนื้อวัว
เก๋ก in ลูกชิ้นปลา
ปลาลูกเถียงไก่ก็จะ
ที่ 3 อันไหนลูกชิ้นปลาอันใดลูกชิ้นหมู
ครับ
ถามแต่ถ้าไม่รู้ถามถ้ารู้ก็ชี้มากตายครับ
โหถ้าเราเอาแล้วเอาลูกชิ้นปลา 2
เอาไส้กรอก 1 ไปก่องหนึ่ง
เอาไปยังค่ะน้าเอาไปยากมีคนแม่ขาแม่ค้าก็
จะเอาลูกชิ้นไปย่างนี้นี่ยาวครับอ๋อเมื่อ
กี้กูเห็นที่รถเข็นมี
มีอะไรครับอ๋ออ๋อให้มีด้วยครับเป็นน้ำ
จิ้มน้ำจิ้มจิ้มจะมี 2 ใช่ไหมคะมีเพจไหม
ครับกับไม่เผ็ดอ่ะได้ครับมีเผ็ดมากกับ
เผ็ดนิดหน่อยอ่าเป็นน้ำจืดกว่าหัว
หน้าใกล้ๆน้ำจิ้มมีอะไรคะใกล้ๆน้ำจิ้มตรง
นี้หรอครับใช่ค่ะ
อันนี้แฟนปลาหมึกครับ
ปลาหมึกหน้าเป็นปลาหมึกไม่ใช่ลูกชิ้นเป็น
ปลาหมึกอา
ไข่ปลาหมึกใช่ไหมครับน่ากินไข่
หนอานิไข่ประเมิน
ใช่ครับ
แล้วก็มีน้ำจิ้มเนาะหน้านะครับ
เราลูกชิ้นย่างค่ะนี่ครับไม่ย่างแล้วอ่ะ
ตอนนี้ย่างลูกชิ้นนะมีลูกชิ้นปลาหมึกนี่
ถ้ามีไส้กรอกนะมีลูกชิ้น
กุ้งหรือเปล่าครับลูกชิ้นกุ้งค่ะกุ้งไง
ครับมาย่าง
ยามว่าตตี้มียางเนี่ยผู้วางบนอะไรคะอ้า
วางบนตะแกรงครับบนตะแกรงงาๆแล้วก็ข้างใต้
ตะแกรงมีอะไรช่างใต้สีแดงมีถ่านถ่านไฟ
ร้อนให้ในขับร้อนๆๆครับตะแกรงอยู่บนเตา
ย่างใช่ไหมคะใต้ครับตะแกรงก็อยู่บนเตา
ย่างอาเต๋ายากร้อนอ้าวร้อนร้อนๆหน้าลูก
ชิ้นเกาะกินได้เอามายากใช่หันด้วยใช่ไหม
อ่ะใช่ครับหันฮะ
ขับว้าวเวลายางก็จะมีกลิ่นหอม
หอมชายมีกลิ่นออกมามากผมขอยางเสร็จแล้ว
ขับทำอะไรอ้ายะห่างเสร็จแล้วก็กินไม่ได้
ครับกินได้ออกแต่ก่อนที่จะกิจเวลากินต้อง
ต้องนี่จิ้มน้ำจิ้มด้วยครับอ๋ออ่าน้ำจิ้ม
ตายครับมีน้ำจิ้มคูเอชอบน้ำจิ้มหวานหรือ
น้ำจิ้มเผ็ดกับครูเอ๋ชอบน้ำจิ้มหวานเผ็ด
รวมกันใส่ 2 น้ำจิ้มเลยใส่น้ำจิ้มกว่าสาร
และก็ใส่น้ำจิ้มเผ็ดรวมกัน Oz  Eye การมี
สองรวมกันน้อมารวมกันนะคะใช่ครับรู Arty
แล้วครับเวลาถ้าครูเอ๋ซื้อลูกชิ้นแต่ยัง
ไม่คิดกินตอนนี้อ๋อ
จิ้มน้ำจิ้มเลยไม่โอเคจะพูดอะไรดีอาร์
แม่ค้าแม่ค้าจะถามหาเวลาเราซื้อลูกชิ้น
ถามว่าเอาลูกชิ้นอ่าแยกแยกน้ำจิ้มหรือราด
น้ำจิ้มห่าถ้าแยกมีครับ
ถ้าแยกนะแม่ค้าก็จะใส่ลูกชิ้นในถุงแล้วก็
น้ำจิ้มไม่ใส่น้ำจิ้มใส่ถุงเล็กๆ 5 ใส่
ถุงเล็กๆแยกกัน
แยกใช้ครับอ่าแยกน้ำจิ้มนะอ่าแต่ครู Arty
ชอบแยกหรือชอบจิ้มผาหาครัวตี้ชอบอาราดลง
ไปจิ้มเลยครับกินเลยเมื่อกี้ไม่กินที่
บ้านกี่โมงที่ร้านเลยจ้ายมีลูกชิ้นใส่ถุง
คุณแม่น้ำจิ้มเขาก็จิ้มน้ำจิ้มกับปลา
r&i ครับราดลงมาในถุงรวมกันนะกวนตีก็ยี่
กิน
ได้เลยจ้าๆๆๆอร่อยครับอร่อยมาก
ขับนะ
มีน้ำต่อกู Arty ลูกมีลูกชิ้นอีกแบบลูก
ชิ้นเนี่ยหนึ่งไม้ขับราคาประมาณเท่าไหร่
คะลูกชิ้น 1 ไม้ราคาประมาณอามิ 10 บาท
หน้า 50 บาท
ถ้าลูกชิ้นอย่างอ่าถ้าเป็น
ไข่ปลาหมึกหน้าใครปลาหมึกจะแพงกว่าอ่ะแพง
กว่านิดนึงอ้ะจะเป็น 20 บาท
20 บาทตายครับน้าหาบ้านพี่สาว 20 ด้วยนะ
โอ้ยใช่ครับหน้ามีบางแห่ง 10 แพงขับค่ะ
แล้วถ้าลูกชิ้นนัดว่าจะ 10 บาทได้ขำ 10
บาทมี 10 บาท 10 บาท 10 บาท
หาค่ะ
มีลูกชิ้นครับ
ติ้ง 5 ถ้านักเรียนไม่ชอบปิ้งมีรูปชิมทอด
ด้วยครับ
อ่านี่ครับ 5 นี่นี่เป็นลูกชิ้นทอดมี
กระทะใช่ไหมใช่ครับหน้านี่เป็นกระทะกระทะ
ด้านล่างด้านล่างจะเป็นไปไม่ไปใช่ครับอัน
นี้เป็นเตาเป็นเตาแล้วก็มีไฟ
ไปอ้า
น้ำมัน
ชายครับใส่น้ำมันนี่น้ำมันอยู่ข้างในนิ
น้ำมันร้อนๆน่ารักแม่พ่อทอดทอดลูกชิ้นอ่า
ไม่ยากพ่อได้คะ
อ๋อก็อันดิใช่ไหมคะมีอะไรที่
เรียก
พี่สอนการสอนกระชอนใช่ไหมฮ่าๆๆก่อนนอนๆ
เองน้อเด็กปชร
ที่ประทอนจะมีปักแรงอยู่นิกส์แรง
ตะแกรงใช่ครับแขวง
หน้าตัดลูกชิ้น
สีเหลืองเป็นอะไรคะอ้อสีเหลืองตรงครูเอ๋
เห็นเห็นสีเหลืองอ่ะสีเหลืองเรียดเกี๋ยว
ครับเกี่ยว
High ชิ้นทอดหน้ามีกี่ท่อเดี๋ยวทอดใช่
ครับถ้าเป็นสีชมพูก็ไส้กรอกทอดดีๆเป็นไส้
กรอกทอดการเนอะ
โอเคชอบชอบกินลูกชิ้นทอดหรือหรือชอบกิน
ลูกชิ้น
ปิ้งครับ
เป็นจริงอ่ะครูเอ๋ชอบกินลูกชิ้นทอดอาหาร
ซ้ำขอร้องแต่กินลูกชิ้นทอดแล้วก็ขอ
เจ็บคอขอกินลูกชิ้นทอดเจ็บคอถอดไม่ได้
ออกไม่มีเสียงใช่ไหมเจ็บคอ
ขอหาเอกก็เลยไม่กินลูกชิ้นทอด
ลูกชิ้นปิ้งหนอกินลูกชิ้นปิ้งแบบนี้ใช่
ไหม
โอเคอร่อยหาครับแปลงใกล้ๆบ้านครูเอ๋ไม่
ใช้ 10 บาทก็ขอใกล้ๆบ้านครูเอ๋เข้าไหร่
ครับ 15 บาทช่อ 15 สบาทแคแกงแห้ง 15 บาท
อ๋ออ๋อ 1 ไม้ 15 บาทแทงในค่ะหน้าบ้านครัว
ตี้ 1 ไม้ 10 บาท 10 บาทไม่แพงหาใจแพง
ครูเห็นแล้วก็อย่าคิดลูกชิ้นลูกชิ้นลูก
ชิม
อยากกินลูกฟิตนี้เสร็จครูเอ๋ต้องวิ่ง
ไป
ซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตลูกชิ้นอ๋อแล้วก็ปิ้งเอง
ร้องเองเองนอนต้องปิ้ง XV ไม่ไปไม่ไปซื้อ
ที่ที่รถลูกชิ้นด้วยไหมไม่ไปไม่ซื้อไม่
ไม่มี
รถลูกชิ้นจะตั้งเวลามืดๆมึงพอตอนหมื่นใช่
ไหมตอนนี้ไม่มาไงหน้ามาเวลาอ่ะ 19:00 น
อ่ะอ๋ออ๋อมาเวลา 19:00 นมาตอนไหนครับ
เดี๋ยวนะตอนนี้ 10 โมง 10 โมงไม่มามาตอน
มาตอนนี้ตอนนี้จะไม่ออกปวดที่วาดเก็บ
นาฬิกานี้ยินเสียงสั้นๆ
เขียนดีกว่า
มาตอน 19:00 นใช่ไหม 19:00 นถึง 07:00 น
ต้องเป็น 7 งั้น 7pm อ่า
507 จะเป็น PM เนาะชาใช่คิดจะมาตอน 19:00
น 19:00 นโอเค
คิดกินตอนนี้กูเอกต้องวิ่งไปบีทีเอสแล้ว
ก็
เด็กซ์เธอฉันพร้อมตรงขออะไรก็ลงไปซื้อที่
ซุปเปอร์มาเก็ตใช่ไหมออกพร้อมผมเจ้ามีรถ
เข็นอ่ะอ้อหรออ๋อๆๆๆ
บ้านครูเอ๋
อ่อนนุชไม่มีหินไม่มีรถเข็นตอนกลางวันใช่
ไหมใกล้ๆบ้านต้อง 19:00 นอ่ะอ๋อโอเค
ลูกชิ้นเห็นแล้วก็หิวนะลูกชิ้น
ที่ประเทศไทยรถเข็นลูกชิ้นครูเห็นนะคะครู
เห็น of  BTS  LINE
r-top ลง
จตุจักรจตุจักรมีรถลูกยิ้มมีรถเข็นลูก
ชิ้นเยอะเลยแล้วก็
นนทบุรีเนาะอ้านนทบุรีที่มีมากก็ได้เขา
ใกล้ๆบ้านครูเอ๋ไม่มีไม่มีเซเว่น
อีเลฟเว่นอ๋อ
5  kuai ซื้อลูกชิ้นจากซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ต
คูเวตต้องซื้อน้ำจิ้มด้วยไหมครับให้หา
ต้องซื้อซิมคำน้ำจิ้มไม่เป็นเป็นแสบครัว
ตี้ก็ทำไม่เป็น
หน้ามีน้ำจิ้มขายไหมคะได้มีน้ำจิ้มขาย
อาหารน้ำจิ้มในซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตมีขายอ่ะ
อ่าใส่ขวดค่ะน้าๆครับอ๋อโอเคเลยเดี๋ยวกู S
คลิปนี้แล้วจะวิ่งไปซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ต 5
ซื้อลูกชิ้น
น้ำจิ้ม
ก็คู๋ซื้อน้ำจิ้มไควเอทต้องถ้าซื้อ
อันนี้ด้วยครับไม้เสียบพิมพ์ชิ้นได้ให้
เสียงวิธีที่
ใช่ครับต้องเสียบต้องเสียบเป็นแบบนี่แบบ
นี้ไม้เสี่ยงครับไม้เสียบลูกชิ้นทำจาก
อะไรคะอ้อมาให้เสียบลูกชิ้นทำจากไม้ไผ่
ครับ 5 ลิตรใหม่ 5 ไม้ไผ่นี่ครับนี่เป็น
ตอนไผ่อ้าเราก็ตัดอาจต้นไผ่มาตัด
น้าใช่ครับแล้วเอามาเอามาทำเป็นไม้เสียบ
ลูกชิ้น
หน้าใช่ครับ R ตรงไฟล์คือแล้วก็กินใต้ๆ
ครับตรงปลายแหลมใช่แหลมใช่ครับตรงปลายก็
จะแหลมอันนี่แหล่
อาอ้าใช่ครับเหมือนที่กูเอกปากกาคุยแหลม
ช่ายม้ายเสริมปลายแหลมมีครับใครแหลนให้
กูอาร์ตี้ขับลูกชิ้นมีรถเข็นหากูเองเห็น
แล้วก็
อยากกินอีกแล้ว
อยากกินอีกแล้วยิ้มตามเนี่ยเสร็จแล้วเห็น
ลูกชิ้นเขียวกินลูกศิษย์อีกแล้วกลัวนี่ก็
คิดว่าอยากกินลูกชิมเหมือนกันเหมือนกันนะ
คะให้ทำกู Arty ครับหินบ่อยไหมคะอ้าน่า
กลัวติ๊กกินลูกชิ้น
[เพลง]
ประมาณประมาณ
อาทิตย์ละ 2 ครั้ง
7 วันเนี้ยเจ็บมันอีกครั้งสองครั้งชาย
ขับหน้า
ครูเอ๋
Way กินบ่อยไหมครับกินบ่อยปีโห้
ปี 1 ปีกินทีมกี่ครั้งครับคิดว่า1ปี
1ครั้ง
1ปี1ครั้งไม่บ่อยไม่ค่อยๆไม่ๆครับจริงๆ
ครูเอ๋ชอบ
ไม่ดูไม่ดู
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
กล้วยตี๊ดพ่อแม่กินรูปอ่ะน่ากิน
อาทิตย์ละ 2 ครั้ง
ว่าเพราะว่า
คุณจะไปวาดนะคะเอ้อ
สิพ่อพ่อ
แม่
ๆครูเอ๋สาถามโทรหาแม่มีพี่สาวขอสาวพี่สาว
ปนิ
ห้ามเอ๋เอ๋กินลูกชิ้นขอ
ห้ามห้ามทำไมห้ามครับตั้งแต่ a เด็กๆ
เพราะกินแล้วไม่สบายหมอ
ก็เลยห้ามกินลูกชิ้น
คู่เอกต้องกินกินแครอทกินบล็อคโคลี่
ลองกิน path สมัยจีนผ่าค่ะ
ห้ามกินลูกชิ้นนางอร
ก็เลยไม่ได้กินก็เลยกินปีละ 1 ครั้งครั้ง
กิน
7 วัน 2 ครั้งจะอ่ะผมขอไม่สบายไม่สบาย
สายให้สบายครัวตี้กินได้ควรติไม่มีใคร
ห้ามไม่มีใครฮะตัวติแข็งแรงแข็งแรงแข็ง
แรงกิมได้เลยครับดีค่ะ
ชอบจะห้ามกิน
[เพลง]
อะที่เวลาพระแล้วใช่ครับเวลาหมดอีกแล้ว
ตอนนี้หมดเวลาแล้ว
แล้วคู่เอกก็ต้องไป
ทำงานขอไปทำงานเปิดดีคิดว่ากูเอกเจ้าไป
ซื้อลูกชิ้นไม่ซื้อเนอะเมื่อซื้ออ่าก็ยัง
ต้องพูดพูดพูดอีก 2 ชั่วโมงขอต้องทำงานทำ
งานทำงาน ok หัวหน้างานวันนี้ครัวตี้นะ
ครับครูเอ๋แล้วต้องลานักเรียนไปก่อนครับ
อ่าวันนี้ครับผมสวัสดีครับผมสวัสดีครับ
ครูเอ๋สวัสดีครับนักเรียนบ๊ายบาย